so when we talk about something like
stages of cognitive development or
stages of moral development or stages of
spiritual development we're talking
about structures of mind and these
develop in a predictable unfold of
unfolding pattern throughout the course
of someone's life but it's important to
realize that these structures of how we
orient toward spirituality
don't aren't actually the same thing as
these sort of stages of realization or
stages of spiritual awakening we need to
be both woke mean that through our
spiritual development we understand the
plurality of existence we understand how
systems interact with each other we
understand social inequalities etc and
we need to be awake we need to be both
woke and awake woke meaning that we have
a capacity to understand the complexity
of our current systems and awake
meaning that we've come to know
ourselves as this unbounded wholeness so
you can be a woke and not wake you can
be woke up but not awake and wake but
not woke we need both of those
[Applause]